ahora hablemos de la respuesta moral que
trata con los linfocitos b entonces
vamos a dibujar un linfocito ven a una
célula ven estas son un subconjunto de
los glóbulos blancos llamados linfocitos
que se originan en la médula ósea la ven
es por la bolsa de fabricio pero no
entraremos en estos detalles por ahora
las células vez tienen cerca de 10.000
proteínas como éstas en su superficie a
mí me emociona mucho hablar de las
células ven y ahora les diré por qué
tienen estas proteínas que se ven algo
así vamos a dibujar solo un par de ellas
más o menos así y este en realidad es un
complejo de cuatro proteínas diferentes
podemos llamar a estas proteínas
anticuerpos asociados a la membrana
vamos a escribirlo
seguramente has escuchado la palabra
anticuerpo tenemos anticuerpos para tal
y tal gripe o tal y tal virus hablaremos
con más detalle de los anticuerpos en
vídeos futuros sin embargo los
anticuerpos son solo proteínas a menudo
se refieren a ellos como
inmunoglobulinas anticuerpos e
inmunoglobulinas son palabras
equivalentes y son sólo proteínas ahora
bien estos están en la superficie de la
membrana de las células están asociados
a la membrana normalmente cuando las
personas hablan de los anticuerpos están
hablando de los anticuerpos libres es
decir aquellos que solo están flotando
por allí y pronto entraremos en detalles
de cómo se producen
ahora lo que es muy muy muy muy
interesante sobre los anticuerpos
asociados a la membrana y las células va
en particular es que cada célula tiene
un tipo distinto de anticuerpo unido a
la membrana así que si por aquí tenemos
una célula ven y por acá tenemos otra
vamos a dibujarla esta segunda célula
también tendrá anticuerpos tenemos aquí
estos anticuerpos unidos en la membrana
pero esos anticuerpos serán distintos a
los de la primera célula ven entonces
vamos a enfocarnos en esta diferencia
ahora lo interesante es que de una
célula a otra existe una parte variable
en los anticuerpos que puede tomar un
montón de formas distintas podemos
pensar en que la parte amarilla es la
parte fija de los anticuerpos mientras
que la parte variable para este
anticuerpo será am
supongamos rosa y todos los anticuerpos
son unidos a la membrana de esta célula
tendrá en la misma parte variable de
color rosa
la otra célula be tendrá diferentes
partes variables así que utilicemos otro
color sus partes variables van a ser
distintas de esta forma
ahora cada una de estas células tiene
cerca de 10.000 de estos anticuerpos en
su superficie y cada uno de estos
anticuerpos tendrá la misma parte
variable pero serán distintas a las
partes variables de otra célula ve y de
hecho hay 10.000 millones de
combinaciones diferentes para partes
variables es decir 10 elevado a la 10 10
mil millones de combinaciones de partes
variables y antes de decirte para qué
sirven estas partes variables
seguramente nos preguntamos cómo pueden
surgir todas estas combinaciones todas
las proteínas que son partes de la
mayoría de las células son producidas
por los genes de esta célula
dibujemos el núcleo y dentro de él
dibujemos el adn y lo mismo para esta
otra célula ven entonces como estas dos
son células b ambas tienen la misma
línea germinal es decir tienen los
mismos antepasados celulares no deberían
de tener el mismo adn y si tienen el
mismo adn porque las proteínas que
construyen son diferentes como es que
cambian y esto también es cierto para
las células t
lo que me parece impresionante es que en
una etapa de su desarrollo es decir de
su hematopoyesis hay muchas
combinaciones de una parte de su adn que
codifica estas partes de la proteína del
anticuerpo en esta etapa hay una gran
recombinación del adn la mayoría de las
veces cuando hablamos de adn queremos
preservar la información y no tener
tanta combinación pero cuando estos
linfocitos cuando estas células b están
madurando
en una etapa de su maduración o de su
desarrollo existe una recombinación
intencional del adn que codifica esta
parte y esta parte y esto nos lleva a
toda la diversidad de la parte variable
de las inmunoglobulinas asociadas a la
membrana y estamos a punto de descubrir
por qué existe esta diversidad hay
muchas cosas que pueden infectar al
cuerpo los virus mutan y evolucionan al
igual que las bacterias no podemos saber
qué va a entrar a nuestro cuerpo
entonces lo que hace el sistema
inmunitario a través de las células y
también veremos qué hace esto mismo con
las células stem
es decir oye déjame hacer un montón de
combinaciones de estas cosas que se
pueden unir a lo que sea que llegue así
que vamos a decir que tenemos un virus
nuevo
el mundo nunca ha visto este virus
anteriormente y entonces esta célula ve
se encontrará con este virus y el virus
no se va a unir a ella el virus se
encontrará con otra célula vez y tampoco
se unirá a ella y tal vez esto pase con
miles de células para que las
encontraran y no se va a unir a ellas
pero como tenemos tantas células ve
tantas combinaciones distintas de estas
partes variables en nuestros receptores
eventualmente se unirá a una de estas
células
tal vez esta se unirán a la parte de la
superficie del virus también podría ser
a la parte de la superficie de una nueva
bacteria o de alguna proteína extraña y
la parte de la superficie de la bacteria
que se une tal vez sea esta parte de la
bacteria a esto se le llama epítopos
así que una vez que se une a un patógeno
extraño recordemos que las otras células
no se unieron a él solo aquella célula
que tenía la combinación particular una
de las 10 elevado a las 10 de ellas
aunque de hecho no hay 10 elevado a las
diez combinaciones durante el desarrollo
se eliminan todas las posibles
combinaciones que podrían unirse a cosas
que esencialmente te hacen a ti es decir
para que no provoquen una respuesta
inmunitaria entonces podemos decir que
se eliminan las combinaciones de auto
respuesta es decir no son 10 elevado a
las 10 10 mil millones de combinaciones
distintas es algo un poco menor pero
podemos quitar todas estas combinaciones
que podrían unirse a tus propias células
y aún así siguen siendo un número enorme
de combinaciones que muy probablemente
se unan al menos a una parte de un
patógeno de un virus o de una bacteria y
tan pronto como una de estas células
un patógeno dirán hey amigos soy la
célula afortunada que encaja perfecto
con este nuevo patógeno entonces se
activarán después de unirse con el
patógeno estudiaremos esto con más
detalles en el futuro ya que para
activarse normalmente se necesita la
ayuda de las células t colaboradoras
pronto estudiaremos la importancia de
esto es parecido a tener un mecanismo a
prueba de fallos para tu sistema
inmunitario pero no quiero confundirte
en este vídeo entonces en este caso
vamos a suponer que para la activación
solo se necesita esta unión con el
patógeno ahora bien una vez que esta
célula vez se active
empezará a clonar se va a decir yo soy
el tipo que puede coincidir con este
virus entonces empezará a clonar se
empezará a dividirse y a repetirse a sí
mismo y existirán múltiples versiones de
esta célula tendremos sus receptores
recuerda tienen 10.000 de ellos así que
solo dibujaremos
en cada membrana así que empezará a
replicarse y a diferenciarse
diferenciarse significa empezar a tomar
papeles particulares por lo tanto
tendremos dos formas de diferenciación
se producirán miles de estas copias y
algunas de ellas se convertirán en
células de memoria que básicamente son
células que se quedarán mucho tiempo con
la parte variable perfecta de su
receptor y habrá muchas más de las que
había originalmente y entonces si este
patógeno invade nuestro cuerpo
diez años después vamos a tener más de
estas células rondando por allí y será
más probable que se encuentren con el
patógeno y se activen
por otro lado la otra parte de estas
células se convertirán en células
efectoras las células efectoras también
llamadas células plasmáticas son células
que hacen algo y lo que hacen es
convertirse en fábricas de anticuerpos
y los anticuerpos que van a producir
tendrán exactamente esta combinación el
mismo anticuerpo que originalmente
tenían unido a la membrana así que
empezarán a producir estos anticuerpos y
los secretarãa tu cuerpo empezarán a
secretar montones y montones de estas
proteínas que son las únicas capaces de
unirse al patógeno nuevo una célula
efectora activada es capaz de producir
2000 anticuerpos por segundo por lo que
podemos imaginar que si tenemos muchos
de estos vamos a tener de repente muchos
anticuerpos flotando por nuestro cuerpo
y así entran a los tejidos y lo
importante de todo esto y el porqué es
este tu sistema moral es que si de
repente tienes muchos virus que están
infectando tu sistema también tienes
toda esta producción de anticuerpos las
células efectoras son fábricas de
anticuerpos por lo que los anticuerpos
específicos empezarán a unirse a éstos
y esto es importante ya que primero dos
etiquetas para ser recogidos más
fácilmente por los fagocitos y a esto se
le conoce como optimización la
optimización sucede cuando etiquetas
moléculas para que los fagocitos las
recolectan de manera más sencilla y las
ingieran los anticuerpos se unen y dicen
hey favoritos
deberían recolectar a estos virus en
particular además de que dificultan el
funcionamiento del virus ya que tenemos
esta gran cosa colgando por allí será
más difícil para el infiltrarse en las
células y segundo es que en estos
anticuerpos tenemos dos cadenas pesadas
idénticas y dos cadenas ligeras
idénticas además cada uno tiene su parte
variable muy específica y cada una de
estas ramas puede unirse al epítopos de
un virus entonces puedes imaginar qué
pasará si esta rama se une a un epítopos
y esta otra rama
a otro virus de repente estos virus
quedarán juntos y pegados por lo que
serán menos eficientes no serán capaces
de hacer lo que normalmente hacen no
serán capaces de penetrar las membranas
celulares y además están perfectamente
etiquetados están optimizados para que
los fagocitos los ingieren hablaremos
más sobre las células ve en el futuro
pero encuentro fascinante que existan
tantas combinaciones y que haya
suficientes combinaciones para reconocer
casi cualquier cosa que existan en los
fluidos de nuestro cuerpo pero todavía
no hemos resuelto todas las preguntas
todavía no hemos resuelto la pregunta de
qué pasará cuando un patógeno se
infiltra en una célula o cuando tenemos
células cancerígenas cómo vamos a matar
células que claramente se han
descarrilado nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo